oh yeah yeah this was this wasn't so
much
uh odd this wasn't being hit on but this
is just a funny story i wanted to tell
you so uh one time uh there was uh i was
at a convention
and i actually have this guy on facebook
still so it's really nice but it was
just it was very strange and things
get added on and adding on where i went
to it and they were like okay so you
when you go to convention as a guest
you typically if it's like a big
convention you'll get like a handler
like it's like an assistant yeah
basically someone who makes sure that
you turn up to your appointments on time
and also if you need anything or like
you say you're signing things and you
you know you run out of sharpies like
give me a shop real quick
uh they'll do stuff like that and um uh
the guy i had he was like oh yeah my
daughter's a big fan
i'm like oh cool cool that's that's
awesome he's like would you mind like
saying hi to her and i'm like yeah of
course of course like i'll hang out with
him
yeah and then he was really nice and he
helped me out a lot he always got me
whatever i needed
and then uh he was like yeah do you want
to like come for like a
family dinner with me and my family oh
okay
uh i mean i i felt like i had to say yes
but like i was like oh sure i mean of
course like i don't mind i mean this
guy's helping you out right yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean i literally had
nothing better than you i was like yeah
sure why not you know real nice so yeah
i'd love to meet your family his family
was like
12 kids or something jesus christ and
like half of them half of them knew who
i was and half them didn't care
yeah it was like it was like being in
the middle of a half a dozen what's that
movie called like does it
double does it what the [ __ ] is that i i
know what you're talking about
i was like a dozen or something
something like that yeah but it was
really cool because i i think i think he
was like a foster parent or something
and it was really cool the story was
really unique
not being hit on by the way quite the
opposite of a cool story to tell
just those really odd that i got like
roped into this and i was like what is
happening
why is there 12 kids i thought all i
could envision is that
that scene from annie where they're
they're all like eating on the really
on the table you're just in the middle
like yeah
because the dad was trying to talk to me
but obviously all the kids were like you
know it's a youtuber and they wanted my
attention
they kept asking me questions and they'd
be like do you pay taxes or something
like that
and i'm like well that's a four year old
asking you this like
are you avoiding taxes are you the irs
yeah it was it was just really cool
about that was a fun story yeah um
oh god why wow that was just a morbid uh
stoppage i don't know
this is a hell of a stock image i don't
know why this was a stock image but
giddy why do you have anything and what
sometimes you look at stock images and
you think in what context
would someone want to use this someone
what what was the direction they had
when
someone honestly honestly i i do think
there is a like small market i'm
a small market of stock image
photographers that are like i'm hoping
this is going to become a meme
i'm i'm betting that this is i'm going
to take some meme photos and hope that
this is this
is like they're all like racing to be
the next meme right yeah
to become the next jealous girlfriend
meme guy like that
this is this is definitely giving me
that energy right now for sure
all right this is the the unexpected if
you will let me show you the stock image
first of all what a good stocking
okay that's a tarantino shot right there
my cigar with the boys we kidnapped
somebody
so yeah no one one time uh like you like
you said like the the mothers bring the
door
that's just bring the mothers along yeah
yeah um and one time there was like they
were both
really big fans and i thought wow that's
so [ __ ] cool yeah and
um yeah i didn't really think much of it
and
like she was like joking being like oh
you she said i look like like
tom cruise and i'm like i do not like
tom cruise i look quite the opposite of
tom cruise
is this basically every reddit post who
has like a white guy with a beard and a
shirt
that looks like corner that doesn't oh
yeah that's connor like white beard
checks out oh my god
then i was like ah okay and then they
were like oh yeah you seeing anyone like
legit asked me this like while i did
well the mom was yeah the mom asked me
that while i'm signing the daughter's
autograph and i thought oh yeah no not
really not really she's like oh
okay i mean do you want to get a drink
later and i'm like ah
and i was like yeah sure sure thinking
like oh it's like this isn't serious
yeah yeah yeah found out later she was
very serious and she was very
disappointed that we didn't have that
drink
right right because i i i thought it was
juicy you basically stood her up
i mean she didn't taste it
not proud to say it the world is going
to end i'm trying to say it you know but
yeah i do corner i unexpected i believe
it was a single mother as well actually
okay
oh that's like your fantasies yeah
i mean i think they think of milf porn
right
you don't see the kids so that's a big
plus right i don't want to [ __ ] know
about the kids don't tell me about the
kid i don't want to get involved
what's wrong you get married and they
have to call you dad
that's so gross i mean some people are
into the daddy thing right
no no it's the fantasy it's the fantasy
listen the problem with the whole like
milf dynamic in real life is there a lot
of hurdles that make it
very uncomfortable and very awkward
right i would feel so sorry for the
[ __ ] daughter imagine being a fan
i felt sorry for the daughter imagine
being a fan of a youtuber and then they
become your
dad but let's just let's just think
about that for
a second that is a [ __ ] like that is
a a like a visual novel in the making
he was my favorite youtuber but now he's
my dad
but actually it was the daughter that
ended up being like oh i'm so sorry my
mom just gets carried away sometimes
right
right yeah your mum's on like the prowl
next to you with her what's going on
you guys are real close to be like
scouting out the prey with each other
you know what i mean mom's like yo yo
become my wing wing woman
come on i thought it was it was like a
wingman it was crazy that's nuts
domestic boyfriend it's like it's like
love triangles
you know in a porno or a hentai yeah
it's very attractive and right
but you realize in real life [ __ ] it's a
nightmare yeah it's messy as far as you
have anything like that never ends well
that was definitely unexpected that was
that was the unexpected yeah